what about sexual co-workers often
just say you don't care what about
friends stay friends with benefits one
more time and see what happens
i was gonna say friends with something
else really what were you gonna say
benefits yeah pathetic
my friends and i would say that you guys
are just chilling
wait full-on sex is now considered just
chilling uh-huh and mal's stuff is
hanging out
and hand stuff is pretty much i like you
but just as a friend
huh yeah times have changed yeah
obviously i
didn't intend to tell everyone how much
i was making
and honestly i'm quite surprised that
anyone receiving that information from a
clearly confused and elderly woman would
make that announcement
i'm a good soldier i do what i'm told
well i just want to say it's awesome to
see another floor supervisor doing so
well
i think i speak for all four supervisors
when i say you are an inspiration
oh okay thank you it's probably tough on
jonah though can't imagine where this is
going
i'm just saying making so much less
money than your girlfriend it's got to
be emasculating
probably makes it tough to get an
erection my erections are fine thank you
fine lucky lady i'm actually shocked
you're not making more
i thought a manager would at least make
more than we do she does
i don't think so how much do you make
same thing we all make a hundred
thirty-four thousand dollars a year
how do you make that much a year 52
weeks times 30 hours a week times
minimum wage
86 bucks an hour no no no minimum wage
is 860 an hour
i must have missed a decimal point so no
part of you thought to question why you
were making 86
an hour to work retail i thought that's
what we all made
how do you guys live on under 134 000 a
year
i cut the budget i let people go you're
gonna have to pay that back
oh now you're taking his money the rich
get richer
no it goes back to corporate not to me
and who pays you
corporate funny how that works follow
the money people
i can't pay that money back i'm living
hand to mouth as it is
i always say mo money mo problems that's
what you say
you say that i can't believe you were
spying on us that is so illegal
no actually it's it's not illegal uh
it's a gray area
so perfectly fine are we sure this is
the last one i don't know
dina's the one who put them everywhere
yeah amy was just the one sitting
watching us in the dark without our
consent
no all of the lights were on maybe i
should take down all the smoke detectors
you know just to be safe yes that's
definitely the safest thing to do what
other
private areas do you spy on us in are
there cameras in the bathroom
oh my god are you watching us masturbate
at work uh
no and you shouldn't be masturbating at
work
then how do you know i'm doing it i'm
good thanks i'm not the bad guy here
you're the ones who've been sitting in
here talking about me behind my back if
you have something to say why don't you
just say it to my face yeah
that goes for everyone if you have an
opinion about someone
tell them bad or good who goes around
saying good things about people behind
their backs
that's a really good question garrett do
you have any thoughts about that no not
really
we were talking about you because you're
the boss everyone complains about the
boss
wait did you guys used to say things
about me when i was the boss
no it's just something we started doing
recently
oh okay good so when we do need to
masturbate where are we supposed to go
i don't know maybe hold it you can go to
your car
loading dock milk aisle there's a nook
in the garden center that's good
or hell okay what if someone steals a
baby what then do you want me to just
sit there
and watch someone take a baby what if
the baby is wearing
a bomb then wouldn't you want him to
steal it i'm trying to picture a
scenario in which somebody plays oh
what if it's baby hitler oh a very good
question
is it i think you got to kill that baby
hitler yeah how would you know that that
baby was going to grow up to be hitler
what if that baby was going to grow up
to be the exact opposite of hitler
churchill no lance bass interesting
oprah yeah oprah you got to save that
baby
gotta save it i'm more of an ellen
person
it's fun when she dances anyway what i'm
saying is
don't be adina be a jonah
oh wait you guys what if
it's baby oprah but the person stealing
it is beyonce
okay that's as loud as my voice goes so
i'm not sure what to do here
i would definitely kill a wall oh
oh okay okay today is a very exciting
day because
stratus is doing a profile on our store
yeah what's stratus um only our internal
corporate magazine
magazine isn't exactly accurate it's
more like
misleading propaganda no it's not
minimum wage is maximum
fun it is work it off a guide to
injuries on the job oh that is a super
fun read
oh there's a jingle writing contest bo
could enter that
if he won he could stop dancing for his
mom's friends it's my responsibility to
show the reporter around so please let's
let's put our best foot forward okay
cheyenne that means no falling asleep in
the bedding department i get tired glad
i'm pregnant
not today you're not okay uh
oh and sal i'm i'm gonna need you to
take the creepiness
down to about a two okay garrett
um i love those nicknames you come up
with for me
but uh some people might see them as
insulting so why don't you just get them
out of your system now
glenda g nothing glenn gary glenn lost
glenima lentil soup transglander oh
that's a new one
you got to keep this reporter away from
me i hate reporters my school paper once
misidentified me as a scoliosis victim
the joke is my spine is perfect okay
i can bench 160. 165 in the right
situation
okay let's get out there and have a
newsworthy day
do it for the old uh
g-spot see you're not the only one who's
good at nicknames
this is nice huh taking a well-earned
break with my co-workers
i feel like i'm finally fitting in here
you don't get to decide when you're
fitting and we'll let you know
i'm just saying getting used to it
not getting used to standing all day
it's not a problem i have to deal with
yeah well
lucky you my friend
not luck lucky not lucky you that's i
don't think you're lucky so you think
i'm
unlucky uh not well you know what i mean
that's that's an it's an expression
why don't you just eject right now you
know it's so weird that your feet hurt
because every time i see you i feel like
you're sitting
try doing this job six months pregnant
yeah seriously
that's brutal i didn't know you're
pregnant too i was when i was 19
then i gave birth to my daughter so i'm
not pregnant now but thank you for
thinking so i didn't mean you look
pregnant i just been injected i eject i
didn't know that you had a child
i listen that's i think that's beautiful
really i i'm in
awe of single mothers so i'm married
oh you should have just ejected me why
are you in awe of single mothers
i just think it's it's very brave to
have a child especially at your age well
i didn't set out to have a baby came
from sex
right sure uh but but you you
bravely made the decision to go through
with it well i couldn't get a ride to
planned parenthood well if you ever need
one
in the future jonah i'd prefer if you
didn't offer to shuttle our employees to
the abortion clinic no i meant rides in
general what if it was just for a pap
smear could i get a ride for that
they recommend one a year but i like to
go extra make sure
everything's up to code okay i'm just
gonna say it
i'm fine with you driving your
co-workers anywhere except the abortion
clinic damn it glenn
you cannot talk about your personal
feelings on abortion in the workplace i
didn't bring up abortion
abortion abortion abortion abortion
abortions you dug your own grave oh look
how cute
mermaid treasure for the treasure hunt
the treasure is seashells
wouldn't mermaid treasure be something
they don't have general access to like
human garbage would be treasured to them
i wish i were a mermaid i would clean up
i think you'd be a merm man yeah i don't
really find merman as a
thing then how did they used to you know
unless that's why they went extinct they
didn't go
extinct they lost their tails over the
course of centuries and turned into
humans
it's called evolution i don't think so
okay
fine god made us look at the human eye
it's too complicated no i i believe in
evolution i'm just
saying it's make-believe it's like
unicorns we don't know that they were
never unicorns
i read that we discover like 50 new
species of frogs each year maybe
scientists just haven't discovered
unicorns
frogs are tiny i think somebody would
have noticed a unicorn a lot of people
believe unicorns exist
a lot of people believe in bigfoot a lot
of people believe in angels
i believe in angels no you don't yeah i
do
i used to think kangaroos were real
trouble in paradise have you been in the
break room all day
yeah i'm just not feeling it today
you